2022 restera l'année marquée par le
retour de la guerre en Europe la
poursuite de la pandémie liée à la covid
19 et le retour de l'inflation personne
n'était épargné les collectivités comme
les particuliers dans ce contexte le
Sénat sous l'autorité du président
Larcher a fait preuve d'une activité
attentive à tous déterminait être utile
efficace pour chacun les sujets ont été
nombreux bien évidemment la santé hier
pour se préoccuper des effets encore de
la covid et aujourd'hui sur la pénurie
de médicaments qui rend compliqué
l'accès à la santé le maintien des
services publics est essentiel c'est le
bien de ceux qui n'ont rien c'est ce qui
permet en proximité de répondre à chacun
sur les préoccupations de la vie
quotidienne
la vie quotidienne c'est ce qui rythme
le plus la vie des territoires et c'est
pour ça que nous sommes attachés aussi
au maintien des commerces de proximité
nous l'avons montré dans le débat sur le
pouvoir d'achat nous l'avons montré à
travers des notorial et notre attention
est portée aujourd'hui sur les
boulangeries tout un symbole d'entrée de
notre histoire et dans notre culture les
collectivités c'est aussi l'économie
locale parce que par leurs
investissements ils vont vivre les
territoires ils font vivre nos
entreprises et donc dans le contexte
nous connaissons nous devons apporter
des solutions pour permettre aux
collectivités d'apporter de nouveaux
engagements de nouveaux projets et
évidemment animer les territoires
nous espérons que l'année qui s'ouvre à
nous sera belle dans une ferveur telle
que nous l'avons vécu ces derniers jours
derrière l'équipe de France de football
et puis j'espère que évidemment ça sera
une année pleine de progrès je vous
souhaite pour 2023 une année pleine de
joie